5 25 on your friday morning what's
driving you crazy well rookie driver or
not you can't go wrong with tips on the
best way to the las vegas motor speedway
for nascar weekend well the default
northbound 15 to the speedway that's
kind of a duh that'll absolutely get you
but the question is how long is that
going to take so depending on where
you're coming from there are better
alternatives so if you're coming from
the west the southwest and especially
the northwest somehow get yourself
eastbound on the northern 215 beltway
boom pretty much a straight line to the
15 you could probably hear the speedway
engines revving now if you're coming
from henderson boulder city or the
southeast valley even with the ongoing
big squeeze the best bet is the north 95
515 to las vegas boulevard for the
leisurely stroll all the way up now
wherever you're coming from there will
be plenty of signs and helper people to
get you where you're going and whatever
else you're taking may i ask you to
leave room for something else
patience race weekend is designed to be
a ton of fun and it's even easier when
you give yourself the time and space to
make sure getting in and out of the area
doesn't harsh
anyone's mellow man
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone some's driving to crazy
email me traffic eight eight newsnow.com